the jurogan experience do you want to
talk about that thing that you might be
doing
yeah let's do it we gotta push this
microphone in front of you so
you just get there you go like that so
tell me what this what is this
announcement what's going on
so i just signed a big contract bro i'm
coming back to fighting oh no
yeah and the great words of tj dillashaw
daddy's home [ __ ]
[Laughter]
but i'm not coming back to mma man uh i
know that i've been seeing a lot of
people's comment and they're kind of
hoping that i am um
i'm coming back to boxing man i want to
try something different now
you're coming back to regular boxing are
you going to do bare knuckle boxing i
think we're going to throw some bare
knuckle in there bro
just mix it up get real crazy now
i've seen you you're working out a lot
you're hitting a lot of mitts
like were you doing that before or did
you just have this
did they contact you like how did this
come about so we've
i mean this is actually something that's
kind of been in the works for probably a
year now
um you know it's just for me
look i just turned 36 in maine we were
just talking about still having that
that desire like when i when i left the
ufc i was just about to have my first
baby um you know we had i had a lot on
my plate there was
obviously i had just lost but even going
into that fight
i had started a company was working on a
few other companies
and there was a lot that i was more
excited about
than competing at the time and i mean
obviously we know that this sport
is so brutal like you if you don't have
100 mindset into it
you're gonna get [ __ ] up you know and
it's for me i was like look dude i'm
gonna take some time off
um i'm gonna or just or just end it here
i have other things going on
and we'll see kind of what happens in
the future so i decided to retire talked
it over with the wife
and that was you know what the game plan
was so
uh fast forward two and a half years
later um
you know obviously i still have that
desire um
and obviously my my baby girl is bigger
now we are
uh pregnant with a second and uh i just
started thinking like man i'm
getting older i don't want to get into
my 40s and then basically still have
this desire to compete and be like
it's too [ __ ] late you know so i'm
like let's
let's start talking to some of these
guys i've always wanted to box
you know coming off of wrestling my
style even in the ufc was boxing and
wrestling were probably
my two favorite things to do like i
absolutely loved boxing sparring when
i would be training through through
training camps and then obviously
wrestling too but
um i always wanted to try and compete in
some type of boxing competition
um and so uh bare knuckle actually
reached out to
faber and was like hey do you think
mendez would ever be interested in this
and i'm like
i mean i probably never thought about
anything bare knuckle before but
you know boxing definitely would be fun
let me ask you this about bear nugget
why why do they have those like
really thick wraps that go all around
the hand but just
expose the knuckle mm-hmm i mean and
it's not mandatory on anybody like i see
some guys where they just tape their
hand
right but i think a lot of people do
that for wrist support
right like you know obviously you punch
like a bag with no
support in your wrist and a lot of the
times it folds but didn't joe riggs get
his eye
cut because of one of the uh when he
fought lombard
didn't the rap actually scrape his eye i
heard that yeah and that's
you know i think that this is an
organization that's still
very brand new and there's probably
still working all these kinks out but
um i mean i'm probably gonna
tape the [ __ ] out of my wrist just for
that for the reason of support but
yeah i think that's something that's you
know it's definitely a possibility of
getting cut on that stuff
do you know when you're fighting october
22nd
oh jesus yeah it's coming up october
22nd you have an opponent
no opponent yet but it's real uh
chandler arizona is what they're saying
what weight 155. okay so you're not
going to have to cut
no that's what i told them i said look
dude
we just talked about yeah i don't want
to cut much anymore you know obviously
i'm getting older it's harder it's going
to be hard as hell to make 45s but
um if i can go 55s i would greatly
appreciate that and they're like no
that's actually better you're going to
have more opponents to choose from so
i think that's what we're gonna do um
how many rounds
uh they're five five two minute rounds
which i think why are they doing two
minute rounds
i don't know why they're maybe just i'm
not sure exactly what their thought
press is on that but i
i mean i love that i'm an explosive
athlete obviously i think this
i'm pretty much built for this style of
fighting you know i can get in there i
can be fast explosive
quick um powerful and
you know it's a quick round i don't have
to uh you know face yourself
pace myself grind out those five-minute
rounds i can just get in there and knock
someone's head off
and uh and be good so that's gonna be a
big difference for you right going from
five-minute rounds to two minute rounds
yeah dude i've been hit mitts for two
minute rounds and i'm like
i feel like i just started right right i
could go you know i feel good
are you training two minutes are you
doing longer
so that you feel like two minutes is
nothing we're gonna mix both in
and and my thought process on that is um
even when i was trading for five-minute
rounds we'd do five-minute rounds i
don't
we would do more of them but i want my
body my mind
to get used to exactly what it's gonna
feel like because of that reason like
holy [ __ ] it's already over
right you know so i need to know like
you know basically where i'm at in the
round
you know and i want to get used to that
but i'm definitely going to do some
longer stuff too or we'll do
you know like ten two minute rounds so
you're basically just doing more of the
exact same thing
to where it's you know you hit those
five and it's like check you go another
another full fight here so how long did
you have to think about this before you
decided to do it
well like i said it's been a whole year
process kind of going back and forth
uh my wife absolutely hates it she's
like
you're [ __ ] nuts but you know
she's married a fighter yeah i know and
that's what she's gotta she's gotta
remember that right but uh um no man
it's
it's definitely something we sat down
and had to figure out because it's
you know it is something that's pretty
brutal and my my argument to her was
this like
a ufc glove maybe a quarter of an inch
of leather
half inch of leather over my knuckles i
mean the concussion is not going to be
much different
if anything i i think we're obviously
dealing with a sharper object hitting
you
so cuts are probably going to be a lot
more prevalent but
as far as the concussion of you know
getting hit
you know i don't think it's going to be
much different i also don't have to
worry about a baseball bat
head kick going whipping through and
cracking me in the dome either or
someone's a big knee so
you know there's a lot of other things
in the mma game that i think are a lot
more dangerous but
um you know for me it's just it had to
make sense obviously
the numbers they were throwing out in
the beginning didn't
make sense for me i have you know other
businesses that are
are doing really well right now that are
are
something that i can do for the rest of
my life and not have to ever fight
but i have that itch to get in there
compete still in it i might as well do
it now while i'm
still in my prime and i have that
opportunity because like i said
when i start hitting 38 39 you know
maybe
these opportunities have come and gone
and nobody even really cares to see me
fight anymore or
you know i just don't feel good enough
to get in there and do it so
it's interesting how they're going after
so many former ufc fighters i mean it's
smart right
these people already famous you know
they got paige van zandt hector lombard
um you now who else is over there i know
uh leonard garcia
who else uh uh rochelle uh
she just fought paige uh
rachel ostavis yeah yeah did you say her
sorry
no no no i didn't sir um uh so they're
doing
a smart thing where they're getting
popular fires
or who are you know known for ufc fights
mostly and then just introducing the
bare knuckle world to them and i know
it's growing right i mean it's
it's people are paying attention now
they're watching a lot of fights
yeah i know uh forbes just did a
write-up saying it's the
fastest growing combat sport in the
world right now you know
well i always thought that like it was
weird that you could else elbow somebody
in the face
you could head kick somebody with a bare
shin you can knee him in the nose
with no pads but your hands are covered
with a pad
i was i was like but i used to say like
why don't we just go bare knuckle
because first of all to make
grappling more realistic like
submissions you could
sink in chokes and stuff much easier but
then i saw
chris lieben versus uh who is it dakota
what's his name anyway chris leban's
face got destroyed
it was crazy the cuts and i was like oh
maybe bare knuckles pretty [ __ ]
it is and i think that's you know you're
gonna have a lot of blood
which probably makes it pretty
entertaining for a lot of people but
yeah cuts are definitely going to be
there
i mean like you said elbows though in
the ufc like
oh yeah up against the kids slashed
somebody or even off
off their back and you're on top
dropping elbows i mean those cut
probably more than knuckles i would
imagine but
yeah um i think you get hit a lot more
with punches than you do with elbows in
a fight and that's probably
where more more cuts would come in but
how many of these things you gonna have
man so so here's the situation i'm still
under ufc contract
i still have fights on my ufc contract
so
you know there still is a possibility
that i come back and maybe i want to do
one or two more ufc fights after this
we'll see i'm going to get in there
and ufc giving you a green light to do
this is that how it works
or so which is super cool to use i mean
they basically could have just said [ __ ]
you you're not
competing well they kind of said [ __ ]
you to george st pierre when he wanted
to fight
oscar de la hoya well that's because
it's oscar i know
but come on um that's a great payday for
george
i know i know um and in fact some of
that stuff was in the works for me like
we talked i was
my name was thrown in there with oscar
really yeah which would have been
freaking cool just to say you get in
there and box a guy like oscar but
yeah they they wanted nothing to do with
any of that stuff so
you know yeah for them ufc and oscar do
not get
dana and oscar do not get along yeah
what is the source of that do you know
i don't know but i always see them
talking [ __ ] to each other
it's so dumb yeah but so dumb yeah like
who you know why what is what's
happening i don't know
but luckily the payday i was talking
about getting with them is
what i'm getting and bare knuckle now
and you know obviously it would have
been cooler to say
that i'm boxing oscar de la hoya but
catch new episodes of the joe rogan
experience for free
only on spotify watch back catalog jre
videos on spotify including
clips easily seamlessly switch between
video
and audio experience on spotify you can
listen to the jre
in the background by using other apps
and can download episodes to save on
data cost
all for free spotify is absolutely free
you don't have to have a premium account
to watch new jre episodes
you just need to search for the jre on
your spotify app
go to spotify now to get this full
episode
of the joe rogan experience